violence has erupted on the streets of
mexico city after protesters clashed
with police the demonstration was held
to commemorate the 53rd anniversary of a
massacre which saw student protesters
mowed down by bullets as they called for
democratic reforms
a palpable expression of anger
met with a show of force
what started as a peaceful march in
mexico city in commemoration of a 1968
massacre of student protesters descended
into violence
and though over 50 years have passed
since the massacre the demonstrators
here don't feel enough has changed
the slogan of trial and punishment for
those responsible for the massacre is
still valid
we're here to demand justice and
punishment for those responsible for the
repression of october the 2nd
response
on october the 2nd 1968 as mexico was
gearing up for its first olympic games
students filled the streets calling for
democratic reforms
security forces opened fire
the official death toll is between 30
and 40 that activists and witnesses say
up to hundreds were killed
for years the government has been
reluctant to investigate
but one member of the 1968 student
movement said protests will not stop
until those behind the massacre face
justice
we won't forget october the 2nd and the
struggle will continue no matter who is
in government we will continue to
denounce it we are the voice of those
who demand justice and we are the voice
of those who have the right to tell the
truth
until the events of that day are
officially acknowledged the memory of
the massacre will continue to haunt
mexico